trickery
you just gave me a [__] frosting with
cinnamon roll and you're like do you
like your two-part food I'm like I think
that's one food
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
amazing episode of the careful boys
where we are currently off the Record
the record all right okay this is a I'm
nervous two-part OTR prompt two parts
all right no no no one part for her one
part first a b yes
daily ideas again to his face
let's do that one where where they asked
if you had a knife in your back or a
dick in your butt which one you pull out
first that's the first question probably
the dick in the butt so the three
biggest three parts that's the first
part there's another two part after that
if everybody wants to just answer that
real quick you rather die before being
gay I'm gonna pull it I'm gonna pull the
dick out first for sure not because I
don't like it
but because if you got a knife in your
back and you pull out what if you start
bleeding that's well that's my question
is is it the same perp is the guy
stabbing your back while humping you or
is someone humping you and then another
person goes get off my boyfriend and he
stabs the back accidentally the context
is important yeah is the knife already
inside or is it like more of like hey
don't move and it's on the outside it's
in your back and you're like ah I think
it's in because the penis isn't just
like hanging out by the butthole just
[__] it they're both in yeah if the
dick in my back is friendly I would ask
him to remove it when he was removing
himself
all right so
I would leave the knife in for sure
because of Bart what BART said yeah oh
oh yeah I didn't think about that try to
take the dick out I thought you're just
homophobic and you just want to dig out
no no no
yeah okay all right so I asked uh
recently uh and and uh somebody came
back uh for I asked for OTR prop
suggestions and this one was submitted
by a Janie dang
all right so two-parter listen to part
one all right think about this
think about your most difficult time
during your teenage years all right so
one explain what your most difficult
time was and then part two is what
advice would you now give that team oh
and why is this two parts did you not
hear me split up the parts Oh I thought
that was one part I see
you just gave me a [__] frosting with
cinnamon roll and you're like do you
like your two-part food I'm like I think
that's one food right you're gonna
you're gonna take the frosting off and
go here's the cinnamon without the
frosting and here's the frosty that's
[__] weird don't let them wiggle his
way around yeah I can't imagine anyone
going do you like your two-part food
oops Yeah
we'll try the two-part food it's like
prime rib and then they go here's the uh
juice sauce you're not even sweating
Anthony I was listening okay and I
sounded like a one-part food but then he
was chewing food too two-part food man
so maybe that's why I didn't hear it
he wants a setup in a slam dunk so the
setup is okay think about when you were
in a depressed little teen and you
thought life was over and then you were
in a dark time and then the slam dunk is
what the [__] would you tell and slap
the sense into that dumbass kid
thank you you're welcome that sounds
like a single one Cinnabon though right
yeah
uh so I had I had acne as a teen and
stuff and that was really annoying and
like super like really bad yeah it was
bad it wasn't as bad as like so I had
like I had like a younger brother who
like had it way worse than me but I was
also like obsessed with trying to fix it
and I don't think he was as proactive as
I was Haha a little fun
um but then thank you um but but that
[__] didn't work on me actually I but I
tried everything I tried like everything
and the only thing that ended up working
for me for me [__] was Accutane and
and every time I talk about acting
people go people kill themselves on
nicotine and like you know maybe that is
true but it works for people who really
need it and bro in my opinion people
already [__] in the head from what
acne does to your head that you know
yeah maybe they killed themselves
because not working hard because of the
first reaction you have to Accutane
which is your face explodes a little bit
and then it ends up clearing up because
your face is adjusting but I always had
this problem of excess oil like my
[__] skin would just continuously
produce oil like I remember when I first
started dating Nikki even I used to have
to take it like go from Maker Studios
take a shower at home real quick before
I saw Nikki because my skin my skin like
probably an hour and a half after is
already starting to get oily and I had
to do I had to do four tours of Accutane
to finally make myself a crystal Factory
huh yeah wow were you taking after 10
when you're dating Nikki or no yeah I I
got myself
some Accutane from like India and I had
it sent over is it cheaper there it was
way cheaper and then yeah and then my
health insurance sucked too so I didn't
want to go through that because it was
going to be more expensive so I got it
sent from India and I just like guinea
pig myself with it because I don't
recommend doing that by the way but um
but I I just that was my last tour with
it and then my skin finally stopped over
producing so P Diddy really got to um
you know P Diddy really got to you on
those commercials I remember those Oh I
thought it was P Diddy was doing all the
brand deals for it it's been proactive
oh proactive oh proactive didn't work on
me it actually made my skin more oily
which was insane
you don't have any acne scars yeah your
skin is crazy I got lucky man but um I I
you had a lot I was obsessed with Wow
getting my skin right so yeah that's
pretty cool that you don't have any like
lasting things yeah it runs like some
members of my family they have it really
bad where they have the [__] scars
and [__] from it and I just didn't know
what that was like because none like it
was either some people had it really bad
in my family or nobody had it at all
yeah I had a rough and then I remember
um but people have had way worse than me
but then I I just I think my biggest
thing is that uh that I would tell
myself I guess
uh it's just like enjoy life a little
bit more like this will go away one day
and you will wish that you went to more
things because I used to not go out yeah
ruins your whole like idea yeah yeah for
sure I would avoid lights like this in
fact to this day lights like this giving
anxiety when you first come in here
because I just remember oh how it
accentuates yeah it makes your skin look
way worse yeah so like and it was just
over for like a decade or like when you
take group pictures with people under
bad lighting yeah yeah awful so yeah
that was a big one for me also I had a
girlfriend one time tell me you people
like to comment on my smile and pictures
sometimes but I mean this one yeah
exactly so so this is I'm about to dunk
on him so hard right
[Laughter]
no so um my I had a girlfriend tell me
not to smile in pictures because she
doesn't like my smile and that was my
first girlfriend what a [__] I know so
then after that I just I don't know how
to get my head to smile normally oh my
unless I'm like laughing at stuff like
people there's plenty of memes of me
laughing and stuff like a candid one
it's fine but then if you're at the pose
for one holy [__] wait let's just try it
this is a video it's not a photo try it
just try it with the teeth with the
teeth show the teeth show your teeth
Steve show the teeth
I have to be silly I have to be silly
right yeah I don't know how to like
psychologically I just can't like
because I was at such a vulnerable state
right well you have such a nice smile
Agony kid oh thank you bro no acne kid
don't smile in photos I don't like to
take photos because I'm an acne kid and
then it was just like oh [__] and then
the whole time you had a bad smile
that's crazy for someone to say that
yeah don't smile in pictures that's wild
yeah thank you for opening up oh no
problem no problem good prompt good
prompt but yeah just I would say I would
say just experience things more because
you aren't going to remember it as much
obviously I remember it but you're not
gonna like
you know you're gonna have more memories
than you do of like not being out right
seems like you're not gonna remember it
still doesn't smile in photos to this
day it still gets his right accused it's
like in there now yeah yeah that makes
sense so yeah I'm glad I'm glad you made
fun of my smile that was awesome I said
it was nice
clip that and delete it actually I think
the hardest time for me was when uh I
think like sophomore year of high school
is when I started to drop in grades and
I had such a really severe tethered uh
value
of good grades means like good enough
person and then like I think I just got
so distracted by other creative things
that I I like wanted to do music I
wanted to do so many other things and I
just wasn't understanding math very well
because I didn't have a good teacher and
then um and then I really was like my
self-esteem was like super [__]
because I was like damn if I'm not good
at school and to me the school's
everything which is like what they
indoctrinate into your mind that like I
just had no value like as a human I was
like God damn it like there's nothing I
can do in this world because I didn't
know when nobody had ever come into my
life to tell me there was anything else
to do so uh
at that point like I think I wasted a
lot of time just being really sad about
that which is funny because I think that
strained my relationship with my sister
too because my sister's super smart and
she was a big uh
what is it like a big figure in my life
that would remind me that I was not
smart
we were competitive in a weird way so
she was how many years apart are you
guys two years she was two years older
than me she's like I [__] did that
[__] already yeah she was like in your
shoes super smart and like she was like
always yeah she always had like the best
grades that and we went to the same high
school and everything and then like she
would always remind me that like oh you
don't know any of this like you're done
she would rub it in your face yeah and
it's like hard because when you have
grades it's such a it's such uh what is
it called like it's like objective yeah
yeah objective result of your brain and
uh and and then it it all changed I
think like there was this principle my
senior year we had this one principal
who was only there for two years and he
had uh done this thing where like there
was this one award that they were giving
a student and he chose me to get it and
I my GPA was like [__] one point some
[__] and he gave me the award and I had
to go to this like award ceremony at
this like Bavarian like place with all
these like random people and it was just
for he thought I was the most creative
student wow and then that changed my
like perspective of like oh there's a
value in like having ideas and like just
kind of value being being able to play
every single song over here yeah yeah
but that's like like even that that like
that's the crazy thing it's like I've
been able to do that my entire life yeah
only at like age 17 that I feel like it
was worth anything right because left
brain gets punished exactly yeah it's
just crazy I think like what I would
tell myself is like the application of
what you can do is worth everything yeah
and um and it just it makes a big
difference to not have a figure in your
life that can tell you that do you ever
tell your sister now like wait so how
many times objectively have you been on
TV
yeah there's it's like it's all about
finding your place are you guys cool now
not really I think we still yeah still a
[__] she's still trying to rub [__] in
your face she tried I think she tries to
be a little better but like I think
there's always gonna be like we just
grew apart at such an early age that
it's we're just so on I mean there's
practitioner now and you'll never catch
up to me
I'm a practitioner yeah she's freaking
super I can't imagine someone not being
cool with you that's so entertaining to
me and it's your blood you know you're
such a chill boy but siblings though you
know yeah yeah yeah it's just I wouldn't
know but it's like kind of relatable
yeah we just we just ended up being
Polar Opposites like she's all academic
and all like intelligent in that
different way and then I I think as a
way of trying to reconcile with myself
how much I wasn't good at that I wanted
to be better at alternative things it's
so funny I think you're probably the
smartest person in this room honestly
that's like I would never thought I
would hear that from anybody like for my
whole like youth life I was like dude
I'm the dumbest one everywhere like I
really like thought that I mean this
room is not a smart room
the bar is pretty low our Collective IQ
is pretty low
that's the crazy thing it's all about
what someone like if you have one
[__] per like if someone had been a
great example to you and he's like look
at my skin I'd go out I do this [__]
look at my life it's like just to have
that it's like yeah everything man yeah
I think my story is kind of like yours
where um so growing up I got into a lot
of trouble so like
first grade got kicked out of school and
then third grade got kicked out of
school and then I spent fourth fifth and
sixth at another school so when you get
kicked up so usually in like in the
public school system you go to the
school that's closest to you right
so by the time you get kicked out you're
like on the other side of the city you
just can't pushed further and further
yeah because it's like okay you're all
the way over here so now when it's time
to so I have a whole new set of friends
I spent the last three years with what
sucks is my best friend that I grew up
across the street from were no longer
really best friends because we don't
hang out that much so it's almost like
this theme we're like oh man like I see
him every morning like going to this car
and we used to be best buds from five
all the way until maybe eight now it's
like I could see his life and then for
his birthday parties he has different
friends that come over yeah the ones
that I recognize at the school that I
went to and then now I'm hanging out
with these people from this Elementary
School
but when you graduate elementary school
and you go to Middle School it resets
so now you're back at this one yeah so I
go to Middle School seventh and eighth
grade and I literally know nobody so
it's almost like all the friends I just
nurtured
are going to this school now I go here I
don't know anybody there and because I
was getting in so much trouble my dad
was like I want you to be like super
Square so uniforms are an optional thing
but my my dad was like no you're gonna
wear [__] uniforms all five days it
used to be I think like four days you
wear regular school and then Casual
Friday I don't know it was a Friday you
wear uniform but the other four was a
casual the other days because I think
they're trying to slowly assimilate at
that time that's really weird it is
really weird yeah it is weird and then
so everyone's like [__] it's Friday
[Laughter]
so I don't
know so day one of school I already show
up with
Uniforms on so I'm already the [__]
weird kid that one no one knows
except the wait don't I know that guy
from like 10 years ago so I'm the number
one I'm like the [__] lost and found
10 year old kid yeah then I'm the guy
that's wearing
um you're the dork the Dork that's
wearing the [__] uniform so I'm
outcasted immediately plus this is the
90s so if there's fresh meat there's all
kinds of gangs everywhere everyone's
punking everybody yeah and so I
gravitated towards this these couple of
kids that are really into skating and
like break dancing and stuff
but I think like for some reason like in
a diverse School
Asian gangs kind of like feel other
races are like off limits so they don't
really touch them but immediately if
it's like Asian dudes in like a locker
room then they'll start punching people
like for some reason yeah and so
um immediately I got down maybe like the
first week with people and then just
over time I realized to prove my worth
because
if you fight someone and you are able to
stand your ground you're like coolness
or a legitimacy Factor spreads much
faster in almost a day like you can
almost change your rep in one day you
know you could be the wait who the [__]
is that guy to oh [__] that guy just
fought that guy and then not everyone
kind of just gives you space yeah yeah
so like I think I naturally wanted to
hang out with this group because they
just seem like like they're doing all
kinds of like cool [__] like like
drawing and like the Arts type stuff and
I just realized like but for me to kind
of like not get [__] with I have to
lean more into this more aggressive
behavior and group and then that kind of
catapult catapulted me the first half of
my high school into gangs because now
when you go to high school it's that
same residualness and then so now in
high school when people really develop
stuff like the guy that was like in
concert band is now a jazz band yeah or
the guy that like played three on three
basketball is actually playing you know
basketball but then if you're the little
scrappy kids then it's like oh [__] are
you gonna join you're promoting into
that next are you gonna join Asian boys
you're gonna join Santa no you're gonna
actually bang now and it's like it's
like so it gets hyper focused into that
and during that period I remember having
this really weird like
separation for myself but that's not me
that's not me but that's how I felt was
the only way I could survive was like
like when we're like robbing houses and
doing [__] like that it was like I'm
like this is [__] so wrong but I felt
like that's the only place I belong so
the advice I would tell myself would be
like just stick to who you are yeah and
it's all gonna work out and it's you're
gonna have a much more healthy
expression because I think that's what
got me crazy into Raves after because I
felt like I was so like suppressed from
feeling feelings that the minute I
thought ecstasy I was like oh [__]
love everybody and it went from like
this to like fighting every day to like
that's just home hands we went from
fighting every day to keep Juju yeah
exactly damn that's crazy what how big
of a Crossroads that point is of like
which thing do you want to do but you
felt compelled to choose one for a
reason that wasn't really true to
yourself because you like I felt like
you started so back already it's already
like who's that guy I don't know what
the [__] that guy is like oh I remember
from kindergarten so there's that and
he's also wearing [__] like school
uniforms so you felt like you're like 30
feet back yeah versus if you were just a
new kid you could be like oh yeah I grew
up in [__] Altadena oh cool then like
right you're like starting from zero
you're remedial because I started from
like way back here and then it was like
Wow and they're like oh that's the kid I
knocked the other fool out and they're
like yeah I'm the kid
yeah wow you know yeah it was like it
was like that it's crazy too that you've
gone out of all that like and you didn't
have like a lot of repercussions like
for Robin houses and [__] like you got
pretty lucky really lucky well like I
wonder what happened to the fool that
you knocked out like whatever happened
to that yeah what's she up to
still in critical yeah no I mean this is
like [__] a bunch of 80 pound kids
fighting each other yeah yeah it was
just a lot of fights back then like I
would see locker room fights and
especially in PE because it's so
unsupervised at least once a day
yeah that's when it was time to throw
down yeah everyone threw down you I
think more people got jumped though than
one-on-ones or like one-on-ones would
turn into group fights yeah yeah and
people were just like the older kids
like uh the seven eighth grade like you
know these like seventh graders like
Scrubs yeah yeah it was such a big
hierarchy like the eighth grade like you
and him
and then you just start throwing down
and then if you're then it's like do you
want to be a big class dude yeah it's
like it's like if you don't fight
they'll jump you yeah so it's such a
thing where it's like okay you and him
you and him like who the [__] are you
you'll take him and then you just just
[__] have to do it you could have
just been a jazz drummer in another room